insgesamt sind es 30 holz gesamt mumien
die jetzt im südlichen ägypten von einem
archäologie team aufgespürt werden
konnten ihr alter wird auch stolz sind
3000 jahre geschätzt doch dafür sind die
särge in wirklich spektakulär gutem
zustand den verantwortlichen zufolge ist
der fund von unschätzbarer bedeutung für
den ruf ägyptens die sarkophage lagen
nur einen meter tief unter der erde
warum wurden sie also erst jetzt
entdeckt klicks vom science fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktive locken
und dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen die 30 hölzerne sind
bunt und trotz ihres alters von 3000
jahren sind die zahlreichen verzierungen
wirklich gut erhalten zu erkennen sind
rote gelbe und grüne vögel schlangen und
lotusblüten aufgespürt wurden die heute
sehr gesamt mumien in der ägyptischen
stadt luxor und zwar in der grabstätte
als asif nur etwa einen meter unter der
erde waren die sarkophage in zwei reihen
gestapelt 18 sehr garten dabei auf zwölf
weiteren geruht ursprünglich angefertigt
wurden die holzsärge wohl nicht nur für
weibliche und männliche priester sondern
auch für ihre angehörigen in manchen der
särge wurden außerdem gemälde und
inschriften gefunden
nach ansicht des archäologie teams
stammen die sarkophage wohl aus der 22
dynastie die im zehnten jahrhundert vor
christus gegründet wurde bei der
präsentation der sarkophage wurden zwei
von ihnen direkt vor den augen der
medien geöffnet deutlich zu erkennen war
dabei dass auch die enthaltenen mumien
noch fast unversehrt sind es handelte
sich hierbei um eine frau und einen mann
beide in stoff gehüllt zu erkennen sind
sie an der form ihrer hände denn die
frauen wurden damals mit geöffneten
händen begraben den männern dagegen
wurden die hände geschlossen
laut dem ägyptischen antike minister
charlie talabani ist es der erste große
fund eines solch gut erhaltenen
bestandes menschlicher särge seit ende
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts die
überraschende entdeckung dieses fundes
sei von unschätzbarer bedeutung für den
ruf ägyptens laut ansicht der fachleute
sind die särge so gut erhalten weil es
in der direkten nähe des fundortes wohl
keine menschlichen siedlungen gab das
pflügen der felder oder bauarbeiten
konnten
somit bislang nichts anhaben anders als
oft in dem dicht besiedelten gebieten
der fall ist
die restauratorinnen und restauratoren
hatten somit kaum arbeit und mussten nur
leichter reparaturen an den särgen
durchführen das archäologie team hatte
die ausgrabung im sogenannten tal der
könige ami bereits vor einigen monaten
gestartet dort den luxor gab es bereits
einige sensationelle funde doch liegen
diese schon 100 jahre zurück königliche
mumien samt sagen wurden in den jahren
1881 und 1898 aufgespürt und mumien von
priestern wurden danach 191 entdeckt der
aktuelle sensations- von blieb wohl nur
aus einem grund so lange so gut
versteckt nach vermutung der fachleute
hatte ein priester die 30 särge damals
wohl aus sorge vor plünderungen
versteckt ab dem kommenden jahr 2020
sollen sie ausgestellt werden und zwar
im großen ägyptischen museum das in der
nähe der pyramiden von gizeh entsteht
kann man sich lebendig selbst
mumifizieren anklicken anschauen und
neugier zone hammer kanal abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran